in the second world war Germany famously
invaded France by going through
Luxembourg Belgium and the Netherlands
the idea was that doing so would broaden
the front stretching French forces and
allowing German troops to quickly go
around them and avoid some
fortifications too but during the first
world war when the German military had
the same concerns the Netherlands was
left alone which raises the question why
why didn't Germany invade the
Netherlands in the first world war so to
begin whilst planning for any future war
with France German commanders led by
Alfred Von schleifer knew that it would
likely also involve Russia the original
plan was to hold at the border and Crush
Russia before bringing their full might
against France however in 1905 the
Russians showed the world that their
military wasn't as mighty as they had
let on and so the Germans changed their
plan instead France would be crushed
first and then Russia dealt with the
problem was that the franco-german
Border was heavily manned and fortified
meaning that going through there would
take a long time Schlieffen felt that
quickly pushing through Luxembourg would
allow the Germans to go around French
fortifications and that going through
Belgium were dating cutting through
Luxembourg and that going through the
Netherlands were Aid in going through
Belgium however when war broke out nine
years later Germany left the Netherlands
alone so why well the first reason was
overconfident Germany's military Chiefs
believe that going through the
Netherlands to flank the belgians was
unnecessary because crushing them was
going to be easy so why deal with the
extra paperwork the second reason was
that the German Emperor had a good
relationship with the Dutch royal family
and Kaiser Wilhelm personally preferred
that they weren't subject to capture or
humiliation at the hands of the German
Army the third reason was the most
important pragmatism German High command
neither invading France via Belgium
would pull Britain into the war and with
Britain's Navy easily able to block
trade to Germany he needed to keep some
of the Seas open for food and goods as
such keeping the Netherlands out of the
war meant that as a neutral Nation it
could openly import Goods which Germany
could purchase as a neutral third party
the Dutch could be threatened with
escalation in order to prevent them from
taking Britain or France's side the
German military knew that the Dutch
monarchy would never take their country
into war with a great power and so the
threat of War which Britain and France
would never countenance could be used to
give some minor concessions for example
in the opening days of the invasion of
Belgium the Dutch closed the river
shelled which runs through its territory
here to Antwerp and later to Brussels
now technically the Dutch were obliged
to do this in times of War but the
untaunted put immense pressure on the
Netherlands to keep it open however the
government of the Netherlands weren't
willing to do this because if weapons
and troops travel through its territory
to fight Germans the Germans would have
a justification to invade and so it's
these three reasons why the Netherlands
was never invaded and as the war
progressed the German economic situation
only got worse thus the need for Dutch
trade only ever grew and intervention
had no benefit and in case you're
wondering why Germany did invade it in
the second world war it's because it was
great for building airfields close to
Britain and also again overconfidence I
hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons James
bisonnet Kelly moneymaker Sky Chappelle
kosher wolf Jerry Landon Jordan Longley
Adam Stalter Marcus Arsenal YN hockey
Spencer Lightfoot rod D Martin words
about books podcast Captain side August
of swan Marvin Casal Community Winston
caywood boogly Wiggly Daniel tobian Miss
is it Aaron the white Corey Turner the
magwapper Alex Schwinn Anthony Beckett
Coppertone Maggie Paskowski she went in
spinning three plates and Charles the
first